we have main engine start two one and
the final liftoff of discovery but
tribute to the dedication hard work and
pride of America's Space Shuttle team
the shuttle has cleared the tower we're
at a major point in transition with the
International Space Station program with
the ramping down of the space shuttle
we're changing our approach to
transportation fortunately we have
through this international partnership
very reliable vehicles the Russian Soyuz
and the Russian progress we've also
recently demonstrated in Europe and in
Japan cargo vehicles that can rendezvous
with the space station and then finally
we in the United States have contracted
with private organizations to
demonstrate new cargo transportation
vehicles over the next 12 to 24 months
we're confident in that we'll be able to
transition from the shuttle era where we
were basically using the equivalent of
an 18-wheeler truck to move large pieces
of the space station but for the next 10
years we're not going to need the
equivalent of an 18-wheeler we're going
to need the equivalent of a pickup truck
that's what these international vehicles
are and what these commercial vehicles
are that we expect to demonstrate here
in the next several months
these last two flights are essentially
pre positioning the final spares that we
need to make sure that the vehicle will
operate safely until commercial
transportation systems become available
we have an extremely capable platform
and our view is that we can turn that to
productive uses over the next decade
you